it takes about 30 minutes to get around
no plans for the leaders to take a spin
the summit of course president Trump's
moment to shine but it's also casting a
spotlight on the man who is America's
top diplomat a look tonight at Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo from correspondent
rich Edson also here in Singapore he's
twice met the leader no sitting American
president has Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo has spent hours with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un he has indicated to
me personally that he is prepared to
denuclearize that he understands that
the current model doesn't work before
the Senate even confirmed him as
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo led the
Trump administrations diplomacy towards
North Korea secretly traveling to
Pyongyang
Easter weekend as CIA director and again
weeks after arriving at the State
Department through those conversations
he says he believes Kim jong-un
understands both countries have to take
bold steps to achieve an historic
outcome president Trump is surrounded by
diverse opinions on North Korea a
National Security Advisor who in
February wrote in The Wall Street
Journal quote the legal case for
striking North Korea first john bolton
also argued North Korea should disarm as
Libya did surrender its nuclear program
in its entirety up front secretary
Pompeo has to tell the much more nuanced
approach and when the president's
outside attorney described Kim jong-un
after the apparent cancellation of this
summit will kim jung-han secretary
Pompeo dismissed it we're moving forward
we're focused on the important things
I know Rudy doesn't speak for the
administration when it comes to this
negotiation in this set of issues a
senior State Department official says
secretary Pompeo speaks with the
president about this sometimes several
times a day and that they've been
working on this issue since the
president took office
Pompeyo says kim is also prepared he
knows his brief he knows what the what
he is trying to achieve for the North
Korean people he's able to deal with
complexity when the conversation
requires it secretary Pompeo arrived in
Singapore with President Trump on board
Air Force One
he leaves alone
traveling to Seoul in Beijing to update
regional allies and adversaries of
whatever the President and Kim
accomplished here
Brett Richardson just around the block
here in Singapore rich thanks